I posted a video of Joe talking about
our podcast and how we do interviews and
and I posted that that got flagged they
said that is a a warning uh for the
content and then I got a warning sign on
my Tick Tock account and uh uh uh
multiple whatever way now now there's a
new thing that they're talking about
strikes and uh but it's back to normal
what it was before again but I have if
you say anything about China on Tick
Tock you're gonna get flagged what if
it's a bunch of pictures of she and
you're like I love him like what if
you're supporting him by the way do you
know what's the one video that went
viral on Tick Tock yesterday a girl
talking about why uh politicians are
afraid of tick tock and they want to ban
it he says she says you want to ban Tick
Tock because we're getting smarter
because we're getting stronger than you
because us young teenagers and you know
we're getting this and we're getting
that that's why that video